[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome and thank
you for coming.
I know it's always a terrific
choice coming to an afternoon
session compared to, maybe, all
the other things you could do,
like take a nap or something.
So thank you so
much for showing up.
My name is Karthik.
We have two
co-presenters with me.
So please welcome Vidya.
She's a fellow PM on my team.
And then we have Daniel, who is
a valued Google Cloud customer.
And he's going to share a
really powerful story of how
we use Cloud Identity to help
meet their organization goals.
They'll be on a little
later in the talk.
We have three
sections in this talk.
First is Cloud
Identity, an overview.
What is our motivation
for building this product?
Why should Google even care?
And why did Google
enter this space?
So we want to give you
an overview on that.
I'll do that.
Second, we'll follow
this up with Daniel,
and he'll share the
story of how they've
been using Cloud
Identity to meet
their organizational goals.
So you can hear directly
from a customer.
And last, but not the least,
we'll have Vidya come on.
And she'll be sharing
new announcements
and also be doing some
really cool demos.
So we hope you'll love it.
We hope you enjoy the session.
Very quickly, I'd love
a quick show of hands,
please, how many of you have
heard about Google Cloud
Identity?
Can you just show me your hands?
That's awesome.
This is already a great session.
Thank you.
That is really great to hear
that you've heard about it.
Just a follow up
question, how many of you
have heard about BeyondCorp?
OK, still a pretty good number.
So we'll talk about
all of this as we
dive into why we talked
about Cloud Identity,
why did we launch this.
So a couple of things
that have been happening.
Unless you've been living
under a rock, you know this.
Organizations are changing,
because their users are
changing, the user
expectations are changing.
As people are bringing
in mobile devices
into work, as they're
getting familiar and loving
cloud-based services, they're
expecting the same experience
at work.
And that's putting new pressure
on IT and organizations,
in general, to make
those users happy
and give them a way of
work which matches how they
work in the consumer world.
And this is not going
to go down anytime soon.
If anything, organizations
are increasingly
telling us that they are going
to go all in on the cloud.
The amount of cloud services,
the number of cloud services
that they're going to be
using is only going up.
And three or four
years ago, people
were worried about laws and
compliance and governance.
And there was genuinely
a question of,
is cloud more of a hype and
will cloud really happen?
Now, that's no longer the case.
Customers are clearly
saying that they
are going to move to the cloud.
The question is when and how
do they actually do that.
So cloud is very real.
And then we have data
that shows that--
this is from Gartner--
which says that, by 2021,
more than 50% of organizations
will have an all-in
cloud strategy.
So really, an easier
way of saying this
is more cloud and majority
cloud is happening.
So you guys, users saying,
give me more cloud,
and organizations
are saying, yes, we
are ready to embrace more cloud.
And then there are
other things happening
from an infrastructure
standpoint.
Let me just outline
that for you.
We've heard about
containers today.
And generally, what it takes
to build a cloud service today
is just getting
increasingly simple.
People are becoming really
comfortable with microservices.
Containers are taking off,
and Kubernetes, in particular,
is very, very popular.
We have some data that shows 40%
growth with just the Kubernetes
deployment in an organization.
And if you look at
what Urs shared,
earlier today, that
number is even higher
if you think about
just awareness
and willing to adopt Kubernetes.
So all this is saying that
users want more cloud,
organizations are ready
to move to the cloud.
Application
architectures are making
it easy to move to the cloud.
So with all of this
happening, there's
a new thing that's
happening that organizations
are struggling with.
Organizations,
historically, last 20 years,
have been in this
world where they
are on this corporate network.
They still assume trust.
They believe that being
on the corporate network
is how you get secure.
That made sense.
It made sense, because
your applications
were behind the firewall.
Your data was
behind the firewall.
So it made sense
to protect that.
And that's how organizations
and their architectures
were set up.
Fundamentally, what's
happening with the cloud,
as you all know, the
applications are in the cloud.
More importantly,
the data that is
associated with
those applications
are also now in the cloud.
So what are you protecting
that's behind the perimeter?
There's not too much.
And if this trend continues,
everything is in the cloud.
So the whole idea,
that you're trying
to protect something, which is
a corporate network making trust
decisions and access decisions
based on this access perimeter,
is no longer valid.
And applications
are in the cloud.
And then, besides the data,
who are you collaborating with?
It's an increasingly
collaborative world,
an increasingly
interconnected world.
So you're not just working with
your fellow employees that may
be distributed at other sites.
You're working with partners.
You're working with
your customers.
And you're working
with other vendors,
who are not going to get
on your corporate network.
So this whole idea, of
being on a corporate network
and that meaning anything,
is completely moot
as organizations
move to the cloud.
So last but not
least, we now have
IT working on a
bolt-on strategy, which
is, hey, the old way of
connecting to the secure thing
was using something like a VPN.
That may or may not always work.
It was complex.
If you forgot your RSA
secure ID somewhere,
you just couldn't
get your work done
till you got back to a spot
that actually had that.
So these are problematic.
And you cannot have an
architecture and an access
model that is a bolt-on.
You cannot have cloud access
models built around how you
architected and delivered
solutions to your end users
in a predominantly
on-premises-based world.
So that is the key
insight for us,
where we started to think about,
if the perimeter is no longer
the corporate network and users
are looking for an access model
that's easy, simple,
consumer-like,
then how do we build a
solution, from the ground up,
that gives you really
the holy grail--
the idea that you
can deliver usability
that is consumer-like,
at the same time,
you can give advanced security
that gives peace of mind
to organizations?
So for that, we built a new
solution, from the ground up,
architected for the cloud.
You really cannot take an
on-prem solution and bolt this
on.
So, in fact, we were
privileged that we
were able to build a cloud-based
solution from the ground up.
There were three
key teams that lead
to how we built our solution.
And we'll get into
it a little bit.
But the first thing is
really about security.
We recognize that we can talk
about innovation all day,
but, if you don't have
a secure foundation,
no organization is
going to touch it.
So we have to make sure
this thing is fundamentally
secure from the ground up.
And that's a key theme for us.
Second, there is so much going
on in the cloud that you cannot
rely on an access model, you
cannot rely on static reactive
policies.
We really believe that the
world has to be about smarts,
where we can combine
admin intent--
the admin always has
to be in control--
but we need to proactively
protect the users with data
that companies like
Google can provide.
So a quick example, right?
Google is really good
at crawling the web.
And we know what the
good websites are.
And that's what we give you
when you do a Search result
or when you run a Search query.
But we're also equally
good at crawling
what we know are
fishy, bad websites,
and we make sure that the
users never get to those.
That's not a reactive
policy that you need to set.
That's something that we can
proactively protect for you.
In fact, later on, in
our context of our demos
that Vidya will have,
we'll give you a glimmer
of what this could be.
And this, it'll be something
that you'll see us rollout,
increasingly, in
the quarters ahead.
Last but not the least,
we had to make sure
that this thing
is really simple.
Sorry.
This thing is really simple.
People have told
us that, as they
put these solutions
together, they really
struggle with the complexity.
They deal with multiple
vendors coming in.
There's white papers that
they go to put together.
And there's never really
that piece of mind
that tells you that I
got my solution right.
They worry if they've paid
too much for their software.
They worry if they got too
much software going on.
And more importantly,
they wonder
if they actually got it right.
So one of the things that we
really focus on is simplicity.
And simplicity is in the end
user experience, simplicity
in the admin experience.
So we give you a
single unified UI.
Sorry, there's a timer built in.
A single unified UI that means
you can manage everything,
from people, applications, and
devices, all from one console.
And last but not the least, we
have a very simple SKU model.
We have a free SKU.
And we have one
premium or paid SKU.
You get one license,
and that's one price.
And you never have to
worry about that price,
ever again, as we deliver
additional functionality.
So there's simplicity
all the way through,
from the product experience,
to the product licensing.
So let's dive
into, very quickly,
what is Cloud Identity.
It is what we call a
cloud-based solution,
a single, unified solution to
manage people, applications,
and devices.
So this means not
just your employees,
but also your
customers and partners.
It also means your
applications, everything
from cloud-based applications
to other applications
you may be using in
your organization.
And finally,
devices-- we, today,
support iOS and Android as well
as Chrome, but, in the future,
we will be supporting the other
desktop platforms, as well,
all available through one
unified console and product
experience.
Last but not the least,
this is something
that we introduced
recently, but it is not new.
For years, what we did was we
were bundling Cloud Identity
inside G Suite, and we were
using that to also serve
GCP customers.
What we were really trying to
do was-- is this something that
is resonating with customers?
Is this something that
we should find out
if we should launch
as a standalone entity
in the market?
And the overwhelming
feedback from our customers
was, yes, please do.
We have all kinds of users, who
are not knowledge workers, who
do not need collaboration
software, who may not always
need all the access to
all the apps on GCP,
but they absolutely need
user and device management.
And over time, we may be rolling
them on to GCP apps and things
like that.
So that is one of the key
pieces that came for us.
The feedback was strong
with our existing customers.
So we really took that out.
And we made sure that, from a
pricing, packaging standpoint,
this was available
standalone, which is really
what we've delivered here.
So it's available
standalone, but it's not new.
It's been battle-tested.
In fact, we have thousands
of customers and millions
of users and devices
under management,
because we've been rolling
this as part of G Suite.
Very quickly, what is
in a Cloud Identity?
And what is we call the "single
pane of glass," a unified UI?
You'll get all the typical use
cases that you would expect,
from a cloud-based
identity-as-a-service solution,
as well as a unified endpoint
or enterprise mobility solution.
So specifically, we have a
user lifecycle management,
so everything from
a user on-boarding,
user off-boarding,
when an employee
gets hired as well as fired,
or changes jobs and things
like that.
Everything is covered there.
People always are worried
about account security.
And I'll get into
that in more detail.
But we can protect
your user, not
just from a username
password perspective,
but additional multi-factor
auth systems that you need.
People want single sign-on.
They want automated provisioning
of their user accounts.
That's what we call
SaaS app provisioning.
We have that.
And we have iOS and
Android management,
along with all the
other fundamentals,
like an admin console,
reporting APIs, all of that.
So what I'll do next is just get
into, specifically, why Google,
and then we'll dive into each of
those big pillar product areas.
So this is key for us.
And this is, at
least, how we believe
and how we look at the market.
When we started to work
on cloud-based identity
and cloud-based
identity solutions,
there was always
this classic problem.
Can we actually deliver a
user solution that's simple?
And can we actually
make it secure?
So can we give advanced
access to users
while preserving the advanced
security that admins need?
And so that was
really key for us.
And as part of BeyondCorp-- and
Vidya will walk through that--
that's something we
battle-tested within Google.
I joined Google two years ago.
I set my password on my
first day at orientation.
I have never changed my password
in my two years I've been here.
I've never typed my
RSA secure ID key,
because I don't have one.
I just use security keys.
And so I just marveled at
the way I used to work.
And I felt like
this is fantastic.
And coming from an
enterprise background,
that's really what we wanted
to enable for everyone.
We did that through security.
We did that by
being really smart.
Like I said earlier, we
think that ML data is really
going to come in and
protect people, proactively.
The heritage that we have--
we have seven services
that are a billion-plus,
30-day active count, which
means we have tons of data about
what is good and what is bad.
And we can use that
to set policies.
In fact, that will
be part of the demo.
And I already talked
about the simplicity.
So let's dive into
the key pillars.
The first thing is
user management.
Everybody knows that, if
your user is compromised,
then somebody can
impersonate that user
and get access to
really sensitive data.
So people are
looking for, hey, I
need more than password-based
authentication.
They need two-step
And I'll talk about security
keys on the next slide.
But we give you whatever works
for you from a two-factor auth
perspective, as well as
the security key piece
that I'll just talk about next.
But ultimately, we know
that, from a security keys
and from a user
account standpoint,
there's tons of data
out there, which
says that, for example, by
Google's own internal estimate,
we think there are more than 1.9
billion usernames and passwords
floating around in the dark web.
This means that that password,
that your employee is setting,
is likely already compromised.
So it doesn't mean that you
can rely on passwords alone
to protect them.
You need this additional
factor of authentication.
So let's look at what we
did with security keys.
But if you like your
one-time-use passcodes
and you like push
notifications, while we
don't think they
are as secure, we
want to give you that choice.
Because, ultimately, you
may have a business reason
while you're ruling that out.
So let's talk account security.
Prabhakar talked about this
a little bit, this morning,
in the keynote.
But since we rolled out security
keys for all the Googlers,
we've had zero instances
of their accounts being
compromised.
And Google, because I go back
to our consumer heritage,
we don't actually
use that here, but we
are able to use the
data in a way that
protects organizations.
Because we can now come in.
We are constantly trying
to get attacked and hacked,
which means that we
know and can detect
what an attack looks like.
And we can apply
the same practices,
in proactively supporting
and protecting your users,
for your organization.
So that's account security.
Let's keep your
users really secure.
The next thing that we talk
about is device management.
A lot of times, when
people think identity,
they think about
user identity, right?
So Karthik is an employee,
with employee ID 1234.
That's no longer
super-interesting.
That is important, but
it's not the only thing.
We look at things that
are about me, as a user,
but also think about
additional context
that might be happening.
So, as an example, who am I?
What kind of role do I
have in this organization?
What kind of
privileges do I have?
What kind of devices am I using
to access these applications?
All of that goes
into the attributes
of making a really smart
decision about, should I
get access, how long should I
get access, things like that.
All of that happens if we
can bring device management
into the fold.
So we offer the same
EMM capabilities,
to manage iOS and Android,
that you might be using
in your organization already.
And very soon, as
a road map feature,
we will have Windows and
Mac management, as well.
So that's device
management, because we
look at the device
signals, as well,
to additionally protect the
users and protect the accounts.
So one of the things that are
probably not very well known--
and this goes back to us
bundling Cloud Identity as part
of G Suite--
is that we've been actively
used by organizations.
And Gartner, in
particular, recognized us.
And this is not a Gartner vote.
This is customers coming out
and voting for our identity
solution, our device management
solution as a customer
favorite.
So you already get
a particular rating.
And once you go above that,
that's when you get the badge.
And this is something
we just earned in 2018.
So it's the Customer Choice
for our MDM solution.
We have more than
10 million devices
that are under 30-day
active management.
So let's talk about the
application management.
We have a rich catalog
of applications.
People need single sign-on.
They don't want to come in and
configure those applications
for single sign-on, and
they're error-prone.
So we just give you a
preconfigured catalog
out of the box.
We support SAML and OIDC today.
And we will soon be launching
password vaulting, which
is your password-based SSO.
So if you have a
nonstandard application that
doesn't support the
existing standards,
and they just use
passwords, we can give you
a single sign-on for that.
One last thing on
application management.
We have a lot of apps
under management.
Another quick show of hands.
How many of you have heard about
Cloud Identity-Aware Proxy?
Not as many people in the room.
But this is a great
way for organizations
to modernize their applications
or even lift and shift
their applications.
If you run them on GCP, and
then you have an Identity-Aware
Proxy, what it does is it
looks at your identity-- again,
user state, your device state,
and additional context--
and it can make decisions
about your applications.
We call these BeyondCorp for
your second-party applications.
So the idea, that you can
take your modern applications,
lift and shift applications,
run them on GCP,
and then give them the
same protection as any
of the other
applications, happens
through Identity-Aware Proxy.
So when you sign up for Cloud
Identity, this is an option.
You can always
use that if you're
looking at modernizing
your applications.
With that, let me
introduce Daniel.
He's an amazing customer for us.
He has a foundationally
amazing story
of how he used a small group
of employees, on his team,
to manage a very large
employee organization
purely using Cloud Identity.
So let me invite Daniel.
And he will tell you more.
Welcome, Daniel.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL TEHRANI: Thank you.
Thanks.
My name is Daniel Tehrani.
I am vice president of
IT at HealthChannels.
I've been with the
company about six years.
And in that time,
I've guided them
through implementing
multiple cloud products,
the first of which was G Suite.
But before I get started,
I want to talk a little bit
about our company.
HealthChannels was
established 14 years ago,
as Scribe America,
and has since grown
to incorporate three
distinct organizations that
provide services to
over 2,600 locations
and employ 17,000
employees, internationally.
Our primary line of
business is scribes.
And a scribe is somebody that
follows the physician around
and assists them with their
clinical documentation.
Some of the biggest
challenges we
faced within our
organization, when
enabling our digital
workplace, was we're
a high-growth organization.
To give you an idea, in 2014,
we had approximately 5,000
employees.
Today, we have 17,000.
We also experienced a
significant amount of turnover
within our organization.
We hire, predominantly,
pre-med students
that are looking to move
on into medical careers.
They last with us
about two years.
But we also have a
stringent training process
that not everybody gets through.
All of that amounts to a
turnover of about 1,000 people
every month.
Lastly, we run a
very small IT group.
Total headcount is
about six people.
And we do that, and we have
to administer multiple--
an ever-growing list
of applications as we
adopted more and more
cloud applications.
So how did we deal
with all of that?
So we dealt with
that by leveraging
Workday's Reports-as-a-Service
and Google Cloud
Identity's APIs to automate our
on-boarding and off-boarding
processes, thus eliminating
the need for IT to get involve
to provision accounts.
We also leveraged Google's
automatic provisioning,
into third party applications,
and deprovisioning, as well,
which also removed
the need for us
to provision our users
into those applications,
giving them the tools
they need from day one.
Lastly, we've simplified
our login process,
by enabling all of
our applications,
through the G Suite SSO,
and enabled multi-factor
within our
organizations, securing
not only G Suite
and our applications
but our third party
applications requiring
MFA to get into those, as well.
So why did we pick the Google
stack or Google Cloud Identity?
Number one was the
familiarity of the product.
familiarity of the product--
If it stays, it stays.
If it doesn't, oh, well--
was the familiarity
of the product
to our end users
and our employees.
They are used to using G
Suite from higher education
and in their personal
lives, as well.
The other part of it was
familiarity of our admins,
right?
They use G Suite.
They've been using G Suite
for the past six years.
So leveraging Cloud Identity
was a natural progression.
It's OK.
Additionally, we also use--
all right-- Additionally,
Google's focus
on simplicity and
security really
made it easy for us
to adopt multi-factor
within our organization.
So by that, Google
provides push notifications
to people's Android
or through Gmail,
as well as security
keys, which makes
it really easy to get through
that multi-factor portion
of it.
Additionally, there's simplicity
in security from an admin
perspective, as well.
When a user is on-boarded
into Cloud Identity,
you can set a period
of time in which they
have to set up multi-factor.
And once they log
in, they are prompted
to go through the multi-factor
setup, and they're set.
They're ready to go
with multi-factor.
So that decreases
the level of support
that IT needed to provide.
Lastly, Google's extensible
APIs and the reliability
really allowed us to automate
and move things forward
without any hindrances.
We did all of that
within a couple of weeks.
So looking forward,
we're looking
to further automate
our employee lifecycle
and implement more
smarts, which Vidya
will talk about a
little bit later,
as well as implement device
management and Cloud Identity
for external consultants.
With all that said, I'd like
to pass the baton to Vidya
to talk about it, anyway.
[APPLAUSE]
VIDYA NAGARAJAN: Thanks, Daniel.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Vidya.
And I'm one of the product
leads on Cloud Identity.
So we have been
working quite hard,
as a team, to solve many of
the access control problems,
that our customers
are seeing, along
the foundational principles
of being smart, being
secure, and being simple.
So there are a few
exciting features
that are in the horizon, that
I'd like to now talk about.
How many of you--
I think, we spoke about it--
know about what BeyondCorp is?
Great.
So BeyondCorp is an
enterprise security model
that Google was a pioneer of.
It was envisioned, within
Google, in the year 2011,
because of the motivation
of increasing simplicity,
usability, as well
as security, so
that every employee
at Google can
work from untrusted networks
in a very secure manner
without using and setting
up traditional VPN networks.
So with that goal, the
BeyondCorp security model
essentially moves
access controls,
from your network perimeter, to
individual users and devices,
so that every user
can work really
securely from any location.
So in this new world, and with
this new BeyondCorp paradigm,
Cloud Identity helps bring
BeyondCorp to our customers.
In this world, user,
device, and context
is the new security perimeter.
Google is very
uniquely positioned in
that we can protect our
customers, with ML data,
across over seven services,
with over 1 billion
30-day active users.
So we have the context of
the user and the request,
namely which device
and what location it
is originating from.
That is used by the rules
engine to define and apply
various policies,
so that it can be
used to protect all the
critical data and applications,
whether it's across your
G Suite apps and services
or they could be your internal
apps that are built on GCP
or using the
Identity-Aware Proxy
or they could be other types
of third-party applications.
So now, Cloud Identity helps
meet every organization's
unique operational as well
as compliance requirements.
There might be several
scenarios that your organization
may want to support.
For example, you may have
scenarios and policies,
which determine that temporary
workers can access your work
email only from the
corporate network.
You may determine that
full-time employees can
work from anywhere,
from any device,
provided these devices
have certain security
policies applied, such
as the disk is encrypted
or screen locks are applied.
Employees can access apps only
from company-issued devices.
Or traveling employees can
access app from locations--
cannot access apps
from locations,
which are deemed to have
a high risk profile.
And lastly, some employees
cannot access apps outside
of regular business hours.
I'll walk you through a quick
demo of one of these scenarios
here and, for the
rest of the scenarios
here, please visit
our security showcase
at Moscone South, where
a lot of these scenarios
are demonstrated in detail.
So now here's the demo.
In the demo, what I'll
be walking you through,
there is Mary, who is
a full-time employee.
Sorry.
Mary is a full-time employee.
And she is allowed to
login to her work email
from the corporate network.
However, the corporation or the
organization has set policies
that determine that Mary cannot
access her work email or any
other G Suite services from
locations that are deemed
to have a high risk profile.
So, let me switch
to my demo laptop
here, where I'll
kind of walk you
through two specific personas.
The first persona is--
OK, perfect.
The first persona is that
of an IT administrator.
And here, the IT
administrator actually
goes and sets up these policies.
And the second persona
is that of Mary,
who is now the
user, who is going
to be accessing the different
applications and G Suite
services from her machine.
So now here, I'm taken
to a screen where,
as an IT administrator, I
will first go and set up
an access level policy.
And I'll call this
access level policy
to be of name,
Corporate Network.
And I will define this
corporate network policy
to have a condition,
which allows access,
to G Suite services or
maybe any other application,
only from a set of
specified IP subnetworks.
So I create the condition.
And I'm specifying a set of IP
subnetworks that are allowed
and that are in the range.
Now, once that is
done and I save it,
I can now see a list of all the
different access level policies
that have been configured to
support the different scenarios
that I had called out earlier.
So once this is done, I can go
into the Cloud Identity Admin
console, and, from here, I can
go into the Security section.
In the Security section, I
click on the section which
says Context Aware Access.
Once I click on
Context Aware Access,
I can actually select
the Access Level Policy,
called Corporate Network,
that I had previously defined.
And I apply it to the
root organizational unit,
so that all the users
in my organization
can actually be allowed to
access all the services,
in this case, the
G Suite services,
only from those
specified IP subnetworks.
And I can take this further.
And I can say that I
only want specific users
or specific organization
units to only access
specific services.
Maybe they can only access Gmail
from those set of IP ranges.
So once this is done,
it has been configured.
I will actually now
go and login as Mary
from an incognito window.
So I'm going to be
logging into Gmail.com.
And I'm going to be logging
into my domain as Mary.
And here you go.
As you can see, Mary's
trying to access her work
email from this untrusted
network at this event
conference.
And she is denied access.
On the other hand,
I'm, as Mary, trying
to access
news.Google.com, because I
want to see what's going on.
And I can access the website.
So this is the first demo.
And as you can see, with
Access Level Policies,
you can have a
lot of flexibility
to meet your organizational
unique requirements
and compliance needs
to do what you want.
And if you want to see
more of these demos,
please visit our security
showcase at Moscone South,
and you can see this.
I'm now going to move
on to the next feature
that we are going to talk
about, so Kubernetes.
So I think, in this
morning's keynote,
you heard Urs talk a lot
about how enterprises are now
starting to move
towards adopting
a microservices architecture.
Containers are growing.
Over 70% of enterprises are
using Kubernetes and so on.
So with Cloud Identity,
we are aiming and striving
to provide IT administrators
with a single pane of glass
to manage your users,
devices, and applications.
And we're also looking towards
extending this paradigm
to support containers
and Kubernetes.
So I'm going to be walking
you through a demo here.
And consider a journey in
which an organization, as part
of their cloud transformation,
is actually containerizing
their applications and is
using Kubernetes to orchestrate
and deploy these applications.
Now being an enterprise,
they're probably
looking at using a
hybrid environment that
spans multiple clusters
across multiple clouds.
Their developer teams are
building applications.
And these applications are being
deployed in shared clusters.
And they're creating
their own namespaces.
So now, all of a
sudden, you have
islands of namespaces
that have sprung up
and that are cropping up
across the organization,
with very limited
governance and control.
So in this particular
demo, that I'm
going to be walking
you through, I'll
be going over two personas.
The first persona is that of an
IT administrator, who is also
a cluster admin, who
specifies policies that
govern who can do
what as part of policy
management for these clusters.
And the second persona is that
of a cluster user, who is also
a developer, who is
allowed and authorized
to actually run and deploy
applications on these clusters.
So now, let me take you
back to my demo machine.
And I will show you
what this looks like.
So let's start here.
So this is the Cloud Identity
Admin console, from which you
have a unified, holistic,
single pane of glass view
for managing all my
people, all my devices,
and all my applications.
I click on the
Kubernetes card, here,
that also now allows me
to manage my Kubernetes
and Kubernetes deployments.
So I'm taken to a view such
as this, where I can now
see a list of all
my clusters that
are provisioned and running.
I can get to see a list of all
the different namespaces that
have been created across
my prod as well as my test
environments.
And I can also see a list of
the different policies that
have been created.
In particular, there is
a resource quota policy
that has been created and
enforced across my test
and prod namespaces.
In particular, for example,
there is resource quota policy
that has been set up and
defined such that all my test
namespaces cannot use or request
more than 100 core of CPU
and 20 gigabytes of RAM.
And now I go to my
Roles view, and I
get to see a list of the
different role binding objects
that have been created.
So here, in particular, there
has been a role binding object
that has been
assigned to the user
Vidster, who is a cluster user.
And she is now
allowed and authorized
to run her jobs on all the
different test namespaces.
So now, I'm going
to actually take you
through the experience, as
the cluster user Vidster,
so that she can actually go
and actually run this job.
So let's see what happens here.
So I'm going to reconnect.
And first, as the
cluster user Vidster,
I am going to run
the job by trying
to create a pod within
the production namespace.
So let's see if that works.
So now, I am going to try to
run the job in the production
namespace, prod-next.
And you can see that--
let me try it again.
And you can see that
it will error-out,
saying that I do not have the
permission or the credentials
to do so.
Now, I'm going to try to create
a pod in the test namespace,
but I'm going to request
more resources than what
has been allocated
for me, by the policy
administrator earlier, in the
Cloud Identity Admin console.
So I am going to
now ask for creating
a pod in the test namespace
but asking for more resources.
So I do that.
And here, you can see
that the job fails.
And it does so,
because it clearly
sees that I'm asking for
more resources than what
was allocated to me.
And now, I'm going to try
to create a pod in the test
namespace but
asking for resources
that are well within
what was allocated to me.
So I do this, and,
as I can see, I'm
going to actually create
it in the test namespace,
within the limits, within
the resource quota allocated.
And it is going to be a success.
So, yay, it's been created.
And now, as you can see,
this is an early preview.
And with Cloud Identity, you
get a centralized, single pane
of glass view for managing
your people, devices,
and applications.
But you can also extend and see
how Cloud Identity helps bring
both policy and
identity governance
for your enterprises, container,
and Kubernetes deployments.
So I'm going to now wrap this up
by going to the summary slide.
OK, perfect.
So, in a nutshell, here
are a few key takeaways
from our session today.
Cloud Identity is absolutely
critical and central
to creating a digital workspace.
It helps you manage
your mobile devices.
It protects your users and
provides accountant security.
It meets your organizations,
in your cloud journey,
by integrating with
various on-premise systems.
It's innovative and
transformational,
especially looking at
technologies like machine
learning and Kubernetes.
And all of this comes with
a very simple subscription
and a licensing model.
And we have a promotional
price of $4 per user per month.
So as next steps, please visit
Cloud.Google.com/identity.
We have a 14-day trial.
Try the product and check
it out for yourself.
And also, please stop
by the security showcase
at Moscone South.
And there are a bunch of
great demos happening there.
We'd love to hear from you.
And for those folks, we do have
some exciting giveaways today.
We should have mentioned
that earlier in the session.
And we'd love some noise.
And for those of you who are
interested, please stop by.
We'd love to give
you some giveaways.
[MUSIC PLAYING]